the gunless gathering that they're going
to have this evening in texas where
they're going to cheer 19 slaughtered
children in uvalde and they're going to
cheer their right their right to make
sure that they can go into schools and
slaughter our children that's their
constitutional right fun fact in the
united states of america we have had a
ban on assault weapons that's a fun fact
isn't it it's happened before you know
what you know you know i it even [ __ ]
worked but forget about things that work
in this country we gotta talk about
things like backdoors mental illness gun
nuts guys with gun boners have to make
sure they have the best weapons of war
to kill our children so we have to pay
good money to train a swat team to wait
for another swat team or stand outside
and guard the school to make sure
parents don't get in while the second
amendment freedom fighter on the inside
mows down and tears apart children with
an assault rifle oh you thought oh well
tony will let up on this he'll let up on
just like oh he'll let up on them taking
the right away from women to the
autonomy of their bodies [ __ ] no i'm not
gonna [ __ ] sugarcoat it either i
don't give a [ __ ] they're [ __ ]
murdering children yes the politicians
in this country you dumb [ __ ]
who are voting for republicans those
politicians are killing children they're
standing outside of buildings where
dozens of children have been slaughtered
talking about the back door they're
gonna go to a [ __ ] gunless conference
think about this the nra the national
rifle association the [ __ ]
organization that lobbies raises money
threatens these republican politicians
to make sure that there is the right to
carry and kill anyone in this country
with an assault weapon because they have
to sell those weapons to be profitable
won't even [ __ ] allow a firearm
inside their [ __ ] little meeting you
know why they won't allow a firearm
inside a [ __ ] nra convention because
they're afraid of getting [ __ ] gunned
down but they want to give teachers guns
i said the other day [ __ ] the teachers
just give the students guns why not the
gun manufacturers would love to
manufacture a second grade sized [ __ ]
ar-15 they'd [ __ ] love that why not
high-capacity magazines and all
miniature ones of course i mean it would
be great for the christmas card right
lauren bobert you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
talking about how betto somehow is
offensive and oh my god it's the most
egregious thing because he interrupted
the nra presser the other day where greg
abbott and dan patrick were just
repeating what they were told to repeat
by the nra and she's gonna go to a march
for life or some [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
dumbass ron johnson talking about faith
and morals rod johnson's gonna preach to
us the country about faith and morals
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
ron johnson what are you trying to out
ted cruz ted cruz come on you [ __ ]
break
faith and morals take your faith in your
morals ron johnson and stick him up your
[ __ ] ass folks we need to make
politics out of this i keep saying all
democrats are going to make politics out
of this that's all it is they're just
politics you god damn right we are why
not what other [ __ ] options do you
have you tried everything else it's been
10 years since sandy hook where a gunman
went in and [ __ ] cut up children
little bitty babies with a gun and the
country pled please begged got on their
[ __ ] knees they put out all kinds of
[ __ ] videos with hollywood elites
saying it not for the soft-handed [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] we need to
politically punch them in the [ __ ]
mouth it is enough of this [ __ ]
absolutely enough they want to take away
your children's [ __ ] right to learn
by taking away math they want to take
your consent away from your children
especially if that children has
questions about their identity they want
to take your [ __ ] consent away they
want to make sure they have the consent
to marry your children in some states
they want to tell you what the [ __ ] you
can and cannot do with your body your
uterus what decisions you can make with
you and your doctor they want to tell
you what kind of [ __ ] sex you're
gonna have there's some [ __ ] crazy
loon wackadoo i think it's oklahoma it
doesn't really matter where it's at
doesn't matter where these [ __ ] are at
anymore some wackadoo wants to declare
life begins before conception i told you
i [ __ ] told you doubt me i said they
will say that life begins with a boner i
said it i'll go pull the [ __ ] clip
they want to tell you how and who and
when and where you can even [ __ ] they
want to regulate all of it they want gut
big government everywhere besides the
safety of your children besides the
safety of people in a grocery store or
church or a community gathering or
concert a bar a nightclub a restaurant
nah nope gun manufacturers definitely
have the freedom to make sure that they
sell guns and flood the streets with
guns that absolutely [ __ ] tear apart
rip apart americans children fathers
mothers grandmothers black white latino
anywhere in between they don't give a
[ __ ] and they'll pay anything they'll
pay anything for the ability to sell
these weapons on the street hell they're
even promoting to buy these guns for
they won't buy teachers erasers and
pencils but they'll buy him a [ __ ]
handgun